ne
[Müzik]
duyduysan
Evet herkese iyi pazarlar diliyorum
Biraz önce sordum iş Ticaret Sanayi
Odası başkanı çıktı konuştun mu diye ben
etmiştim
baktığımda da ne konuşacağım İnanın ben
de bilmiyorum Biraz Hayat hikayeden
bahsedeceğim Ama büyük konuşma ile
ilgili de birkaç tane anekdotu var
Onları da anlatmak istiyorum önce biraz
ilkokuldan başlayayım iki sene önce bir
fotoğraf buldum Arkadaşlar ben ilkokula
başladıktan sonra 4. sınıf fotoğrafı
sağ alttaki arkadaşlar benim sınıf
arkadaşlarım
ya ben de gördüğümde çok unutmuşum
aradan yıllar geçti için aşağı yukarı 10
11 yaşındayım O zamandan potansiyelin
belliymiş herhalde öğretmenin yanındaki
beni
Yani benim ilkokul arkadaşlarım beni
görünce şişmansın kilolusun demez
meğerse buradaymış şimdi görenlere pil
olsunlar aşağı yukarı yirmi senede Ben
Diyetisyene giden biriyim Hiç aralıksız
fotoğrafı gördükten sonra dedim ki
oluşturan Benimki bunu benim sonradan
düzeltme ihtimalim yok
ve bu 485 kiloyum İlkokul 5 de 90
kiloyum
evlendiğim sene 80 kiloydum nasıl oldu
şuraları da şu eşim sayesinde Şu anda da
125 bölüm biraz Mehmet Akdağ'ın da
burada bir katkısı var
ortaokula merkezine toplumda başladım
devam Başka ilkokul hayattan sonra
ortaokula matematiğim çok iyi Fakat ben
ilkokul başlamadan başladım yıldan
itibaren
sanayide çıraklık yaparak başladım Her
yıl Babam beni sanayide işyerine götürdü
elektrik tek makine vardı ve o makinede
ben çalıştım Biraz vücudun gelişmesi
herhalde Oradan kaynaklanıyor orta okula
geldiğimde de matematik çok iyi film çok
iyiydi ama kafamda hep bir mesleki
eğitime gitmek vardı çünkü sanayide de
ben torna tesviye ve priz işleri yapan
bir iş yerimiz vardı ondan dolayı da
kafama koymuşum hep Endüstri Meslek
Lisesi'ne gideceğim ya o zaman sana
doluydu
ilkokullara orta okullara etme evet hadi
Hocam çok ısrar etti
Ya normalde şey Antalya içine gitti
özellikle ama maalesef ben yine endüstri
meslek sınavlarına girdim Android meslek
sınavlarında birinci olarak
motor torna ve tesviye bölümünü kazandım
üç yıl orada okudum orada ilk yıl 4
dersiniz ortalaması toplamı 32 olursa
teknik işe geçiyorsunuz biraz daha
teknik tarafta ve üniversite
hazırlanıyorsunuz
ben onu da yapmadım dört dersimi toplam
38 de ki Son ikisi dokuzdu orada yine
ben endüstri meslekte 300 okumaya ısrar
ettim çünkü bir an evvel hayata atılıp
kendi alanında çalışmak istiyordum
o orada matematik hocam söylediği bir
laf vardır var hayatım boyunca Ben
kimsenin karne ortalaması 10 vermedim
dedi benim bir sonraki dönemde dondurma
matematik hala matematiğin ve sosyal
durum biraz daha Zayıftır MSN
konuşmaları çok ezberle bakalım ama
matematik hala İyi devam eder orada hep
kafamda endüstri meslekte bitirip oradan
sanayiye dönmek var
17 yaşında sana ya başlayınca biraz
hedefiniz Sanki öyle oluyor babanızda
size öyle yönlendiriyor çok Babam da
karışmadı Yalnız bana bir tarafta yedek
parça işimiz var bir tarafta motor
yerleştirme işimiz o süreçte öyle geçti
ben endüstri meslek bitirdim
bölüm birincisi olarak bitirdim Tekrar
iki yıl sınavına girdim makine
mühendisine gitme ihtimali daha düşük
olduğu için makine ressamlığı bölümünü
seçtim orayı kazandım Orada iki yıl
okudum iki yılda yüzde yetmişi üzerinde
çıkarsanız dikey geçişle ve makine ben
seçebiliyorsunuz fakat yeni bir kanun
çıktı orada
iki yıl çalıştıktan sonra dikey geçecek
geçmek var artık çok zaman kaybetmek
istemediğim için ben onu da bıraktım
Askere gittim geldim O dönemlerde
ve mesleki eğitimin önemini daha iyi
öğrendim Yalnız bizim dönemimizde mezun
olanlar gerçekten işi öğrenerek bu Usta
Kalfa seviyesinde mezun olalı şimdiki
eğitim biraz daha farklı Oraya gidersem
çıkamıyorum yani çok orada çocuklara ve
ailelere anlattığım için
Sen hayatımın dönüm noktasıdır Mesela
benim üniversiteden bittikten sonra
obamaki tanışık sulu bana bir tarafta
yedek parça bayılıyorlar bir tarafta
Benim 15 yıl çalıştım atölye var
atıyorsun o kadar bıkmışım ki
o atölyeye gideceğim dedim Çünkü
elektrikli tek makinede çalışıyorum ben
şimdi o da rectify oldu gerçi de
o dönemlerde yedek parça çeşidi
1995 yılda Kendi şirketimi kurdum işte
bir kaç araç bayiliğinin Antalya dişli
bitirdim onları yedek parça da
satıyordum çok da işim vardı 99 yılında
benim Ticaret Odası hayatına başladım
yıldır 1999 yılı biraz yedek parçacılar
bırakıp derken onu devam ediyorum ama
sosyal hayatta ne yapabilirim bir
arkadaşım geldi tecavüz seçimlerine
hazırlanıyor 1999 yılında beraber
çıkalım dedi beraber çalışalım yok dedim
ben daha yeni şirketimi kurdum 95'te
kurmuşum Yıl 1999 girmem ama bütün
akrabalarım sanayide ben sana destek
olurum çok yakın arkadaşım
eve gittiler Ben de bir 15-20 tane oy
bulmuşum sanayiden akrabalarından
yakınlarında sanayide yaşıyoruz zaten
bir abim aradı beni mi çocuk toplanmış
karşımıza da olmuş dedi ama hepsi
benimle aynı yaşta bir kaç yaş büyükler
de var hatta
Bu bir anda bende dank etti demek ki
bizim çocuklu bırakmamız lazım artık
arkadaşımı aradım çağırdım Eğer
demiştiniz ne başla Ben de girmek
istiyorum
99 yılının Haziran aylarını herhalde
Haziran Mayıs ayıydı seçim anlamaya
başladım bir ayda O da bir dönüm noktası
ben de girmeyeceğim diye başladığım
gelip teklif ettiklerini Hayır
dediğimizi 99'un seçimlerinde kabul
etmek zorunda kaldım biraz da bu
laflardan kaynaklandığı bir ayda 12 kilo
verdim O zaman taş Gazipaşa hepsi
Antalya Ticaret sana sonra bağlı bütün
çevreyi Ben Traktör yedek parçası
yaptığım için çevre ve çok iyi biliyorum
360 764 seçim kazandık bize hiç ihtimal
vermiyor 400s vardı Biz dördüncü olur
dedik Orada benim Ticaret Sanayi Odası
hayatım başladı Hatta şişirdikten sonra
o dönemki başkanımız O benim yanımdaki
arkadaşım hücresi yapmadılar ekip beni
Meclisi yaptığı başka bir arkadaşı
yazdılar ben de biraz gurur ya bana
istifa ettim ikimiz birden birimiz
komiteden birimiz mesleği istifa ettik
İslamı kabul etmediler cümlede bu kadar
çalışırız Meclis Üyesi olduğunuz bırakma
artık arkadaşım dedi hiç yapma sen
meclis üyesi seçildi nkal
bıraksaydım hayatım başka bir yere
gidecekti 99'da bırakmadı meclislerine
devam ettim
2004'te tekrar iki seçim var bu sefer
yönetim kurulu gelin adayım
ve yönetim kurulu üyeliğinde de 33 kişi
beş oy aldı tek bir kişi dışarıda
kalacak Ben 3. kura çekerim boş kurayı
ben çektim güvenlik bunu dönem giremedim
ama 2015 seçimlerinde
2015 değil
2005 seçimlerinde 15 çabuk hızlı geldi
2005 seçimlerinde tekrar yönetim kurulu
başkan yardımcıları hayatın başladı
Orada
ama o da ne verir Bize nasıl katkısı
olur inanın parası hiçbir katkısı yok şu
anda bile oradan aldığım maaş 180 TL ama
sosyal hayatta
O biraz dünyayı Anlamak da biraz
tanımakta biraz da Yakın çevrenizde
dosya edilmekte çok büyük faydası vardır
sizin ufkunuzu çok anormal şekilde
değiştirir nasıl değiştirir
gittiğiniz ziyaretler yaptığımız
konuşmalar yurtdışındaki yaptığınız
etkinliklerde Artık dünyaya bakış
açısıdır açınızı tamamen değiştiriyor
işime katkısı var bu yönde var Ben şu
anda 37/5 sektördeki tat ödem vardır
Türkiye'de ya bir ya ikidir sıralaması
çok da güzel çalışan arkadaşlarımızdan
aşağı yukarı 40 tane böyle olması da
Ticaret Odasından kaynaklıdır her ne
kadar parasal bir katkısı olmasa da
benim hayatıma çok büyük kendini
geliştirme Sonuçta ben sanayide yetişmiş
çıraklık kalfalık yapmış 2 yıllık
yüksekokul mezunu bir arkadaşım ama
Ticaret ve Sanayi Odası benim hayatı da
katkısı bu yönde çok fazladır
PES 2015 2005'ten 2009'a kadar başkan
yardımcılığı yaptım 2009'da
çok yakın arkadaşım olsaydı
beraberdik zaten İkimiz de başka yanlış
saydık
53 grubumuz var onlarla çalışırken ben
kendi vurma çalışmayı unutmuşum biraz
arkadaşlar çalışıyor Nasıl olsa diye
2908 Kaybettim dört yıl boyunca Ticaret
Sanayi odasından uzak kaldırma 96 uzak
kalıyor
2013'te bir telefon vardı aday olurken
2009'da kaybettim seçimden dolayı
ben böyleyim En azından seçimi kazanayım
ya ben de burada kaybetmemiş O hiç çok
kötü bütün tekrar aday oldum O seçimi
kazandım büyük konuşmanın en önemli yeri
burada 2013 yılda seçimi yapıyorum
meslek komite seçimleri bir arkadaş
geldi bizde çalışan bizim katımızda
çalışan oda personeli
altıncı kata mı geleceksiniz dedi
Allah'ın kulu Ben altıncı kata
çıkarmaktadır
Yok ya o kadar çok büyük konuşmuşum
Vallahi 16 kata çıkaramaz dedim 2013
hala 6'ncı kattan Aşağı inemedim Ben
hala azıcık atayım onu neden dedim zaten
dört buçuk beş sene başkan yardımcılığı
yapmışım orada Yapacak başka def yok
Başkanlığı yok Niçin çalışıyorsunuz
bunun için emek verirseniz diye düşündüm
ama tabii Bizim seçimlerinde olmuyor son
gece ile liste yazıldı yine başka elbise
olarak Ben başladım 2015'te Başkan
siyasete gidince
2015'te ben de bütün Yönetim Kurulu oy
vermesi de Ticaret Sanayi Odası başkanı
oldu sanıyorum 9 şu battı battı tabi
başkan yardımcılığı başkanlık çok
farklıymış
o içerideki çekişmeleri dışarıdaki
çekişmeleri direk Hedef gösterilen yer
başkanlık mış onu da orada anlamış oldum
O dönemler
Çok da fazla ben devam etme taraftarın
da değildim 2015 yılında başladım Başkan
ama 2017 seçim var herkes geliyorlar
mısın Yok değilim diyorum mm
Ben 15
2017-2017 seçimler hastanın tabi 2017'de
O her sorunu aday değilim diyorum
Fashion aday olmayacağım Ve benim şu 7-8
senedir geçirdim en güzel yazımda yurt
dışına gidiyorum benim en çok tatil
yaptım yer çaldır hafta sonu için alayım
hafta içi Tamam olan işleri ne yapıyor
olmaları değilim Nasıl olsa çalışmama
gerek yok ama seçimlere 3 ay kala
geldiğine bizim ekipteki arkadaşlar ne
yapıyoruz dedi lazım yani kim çıkacaksın
destek olalım Başka gruplardan da geldi
Kim aday olacaksa destek olalım kimse
çıkmadı zorla geldiler burada bilen
arkadaşlar da vardır bri 2017 yılında
tekrar aday olmak zorunda kaldım bu da
önceki biraz ilk 2013 kadar büyük
konuşmasan da kesin olmayacağım deyip
tekrar oldum
bu işlerden biridir
de bu seçim çok şey geçti çekişmeli de
geçti Çok taraftan söyledi çıkamaz
yapamaz kazanamaz diye
Ticaret Sanayi Odası tarihinde
girdiğimiz en açıklama seçimi kazandık
orada
ve bu seçimler gerçekten İnsan hep dönüm
noktasıdır burada Ticaret Odası
Başkanlığı Eğer karar veriyorsanız özel
hayatınızdan işinizden Her Şeyden Uzak
kalmak zorundasınız
o güzelliği var mıydı Evet insan
Bu şehre Hizmet etmekten sektörlerde
Hizmet etmekten bazı sorunları çözmekten
çok büyük haz alıyor var ama çözemediğim
şeyler sıkıntılar işte Panda ve
başladığında onu da gördük yani Başımıza
gelmeyen kalmadı arkadaşlar
2016'da kalkışma yaşadım ondan önceki
tane referandum yaşadık arada iki tane
seçim yaşadık her seçimler
bizler için gerçekten kabustur çok üstü
açık içmen arasında kalıyorsunuz Herkes
bir şeyler söylüyor sizin onu yönetici
olmanız lazım
pes 2016 yılında odamıza bombok oldu en
kötü günlerimizden biriydi gerçekten
Yani çok sıkıntı olmadan yaralı ufak
tefek yaralarla taktık o sorumluluklar
ya Nasıl omuzlarımızda size
hissettiriyor en ufak bir sıkıntıda
ildeki sıkıntıda sektörlerdeki sıkıntıda
ama hepsi Sanki sizin omzunuz almış gibi
oluyor pes 2018 kızı yaşadık birçok
insan sıkıntı yaşadık Kredi
ulaşamadığını yapmadı bunu yapmadı onlar
falan her gün anladıklarınız da içilir
düzeliyor en kötüsünde pandemi döneminde
yaşadık pandemi dönemi çok daha kötüydü
Her gün başka talepler ciddi bir panik
onları yönetmek onlarla konuşmak ikna
etmek işleri çözmek çok dua bir
problemdi
o süreçleri de biraz attık ama şimdi
hala işte yaşadığımız olaylar bizim
zorluk larımızı gösteriyor Bu arada hiç
içmedim
bu ilgi alanım olmayan bugüne kadar hiç
bilmediği bir alana girdim Kültür Sanat
alanı
bu 2015'te benden önce yine odanın tüm
binaları benim üstümden geçti için bütün
inşaat işlerinde satın alma Komisyonu
Başkanlığı falan yere 2015'de
beklemişler nasıl gelir diye Kültür
Sanat binası 2013'te geldim hepsi Bizden
geçti Orada mesela tanıdıklarından sayı
İnan Kıraç çok yakın ağabey indir
dostumdur şu anda ya kattıkları bunlar
bize mesela inanmayın katkısı Antalya'ya
ve Antalya Kültür sanata çok büyüktür
mı Bir dakika sonra yaptı Benfica sonra
ne olduğunu öğrendim ben de var olun ne
olur anne oldu geldim oryantalis
resimlerin soyut resmin somut resmin ne
olduğunu çok güvendim şey bana
kattıkları hayatıma kattıkları Ticaret
Sanayi odasının Başkanlığı'nın kültür
sanatın Gerçekten bu taraflarda çok iyi
çok önemli ve bu dostluklar bu işler
şehir için bir şey yapıyorlar mesela
İnan böyle şehir için Kaleiçi'nde çok
ciddi yatırımları vardır Antalya'nın iyi
unsurlarını Antalya gelmesin çalışır
Antalya Kültür sanatında on yıl boyunca
şu anda Kültür Sanat hamiline İstanbul
Pera Müzesi yapar Pera Müzesi'nde
gideriz onlar gelir 2-3 saat da bayağı
unutma sonuna geldik Neredesin hangi
sanatçının ne olduğunu nasıl
yapılacağını sergileri nasıl açılacağını
nasıl tanıtılacağını gerçekten
tutuş sanatın insanlara neler kattı
şehre neler kattığını da biz de anlamış
olduk şehirde bir kültür yaratmaya
çalışır o Türkan Şoray Kültür Merkezi de
aynı görevleri yapıyor şehirde bizim
kültür sanatı yaptıktan sonra dört tane
daha bir iki üç üç tane da Kültür Sanat
Merkezi açıldı bu şehirde bir kültür
yaratmanın öncüsü olmakta gerçekten bize
çok büyük Gurur veriyor şehirde bunların
olması şehirde bu kültürlerin gelişmesi
bu tip sergilerini yapılması bugüne
kadar bir gazeteci arkadaşım dedi ki
bugüne kadar Birkaç soru görme
İstanbul'a gidiyorduk şimdi karşı bizim
ayağımıza geliyor dedi Şimdi bir selgaz
alıyoruz mesela
ismini açıklamak tartı kepek çözdük
işlerini Rodin heykel sergisi Ticaret
Bakanlığı ve Cahit bak ayakta söyledi
şaşırdı getiremezsin sizdede Kıbrıs'taki
bizimde üyemiz olan bir işadamından
Anayın
Bu üçü de Ticaret Sanayi odasında 140
kuruluş yıldönümü Onun dışında Kültür
Sanat Merkezi'nde Rodin heykel sergisi
acıyor ben o dindir onu da bilmiyordum
bir ayrı onu da öğrendim çok küçük
Ekerler yapan çok değerli heykeller
yapan 1800 yıllarda yaşamış ve geldin
açmış dünyada sanıyorum güçlü tane kedi
var 25 tanesinde
Antalya Kültür sanatta Önümüzdeki ay
sergilemeye başlayacağız İşte bunlar
bizim için önemli büyük konuşmaya
geldiğimde de büyük konuştuğum
dönemlerde
ama hepsi başıma geldi kimse altıncı
kata çıkarmaz dedim o günden beri
altıncı kattayım seçime girmem dedim
yine seçime gidin şimdi soruyorlar
Buradan sonra yapacaksın yok Siyasette
şurada mısınız burada mısınız önce
kesinlikle olmayacağım diyorum sonra
aklıma Bu konuştuklarım geliyor yok
diyorum kesinlikle demiyorum
düşünmüyorum demeyi öğrendim Yani
kesinlikle ben burada olmayacağım diye
büyük laf hiçbir konuda sadece Siyasette
veya Ticaret Sanayi odasında değil O
bizim yaptığımız biraz
ticaretli siyaseti Zaten onun için büyük
konuşmayı öğreniyoruz
Ya ben
öğrendiğimiz alıyorum ama bazen de
ağzından kaşo kesinlikle olmaz
kesinlikle yapmam Fakat her söylediğimde
de bunun başıma geldiğini gördüm Bunun
için çok fazla büyük konuşmamak
gerekiyor Bu Hepimiz için geçerli benim
için daha çok geçer herhalde onu da
öğrendim şimdi biraz daha kendi ama
sizlerinde büyük konuşmak güzel değil
benim konuşmalarım hırsla büyük
konuşulmuş şeyler de değil yani olmak
istemediğim şeyler oldu Her seferinde
biraz oradan ders aldım büyük konuşmayı
da herhalde den öğreneceğim
bu 18 dakikada konuşuruz demiştim çok
hızlı konuştum herhalde ilk konuşma
başlarken de 18 dakika kısa gibi geldi
sonra düşündüm ben 3 dakika da
Cumhurbaşkanını Antalya'nın sorunları
anlatmıştım gerçekten
bütün sorunları 3D kadar anlatmak daha
zordu 18 dakikadan hayatından bir kesit
herhalde anlatabildim ya bundan sonra ne
olur gerçekten hayat çizgisi İnsanın
bazen elinde olmuyor Bazı şeyler sizin
elinizde Ama bazı şeyler maalesef belli
değil ama büyük konuşmadan bir
hayatımızı yaşamaya devam edeceğiz
Elimizden geldiği kadar Antalya için
sektörler için ticaret için olması
gerekenleri yapacağız herhalde
çok sıkmadan biraz bir şey aldım Yoksa
ben şimdi ekonomiden gelen Ukrayna Rusya
Savaşı ndan tarımdaki sıkıntıdan
turizmdeki sıkıntıdan bir saat rahat
konuşabilir dim dediler ki sakın
konuşmayın Zaten bunlar gün
konuşuyorsunuz O biraz kendi hayatını
anladın benim de bugüne kadar gelmiş
geçmiş çok özet hayatım bu
memnun muyum çok memnunum ama çok şey
kendi özel hayatından kaybettim ama
Antalya için bir şeyler yaptırma da
inanıyorum Bundan sonra biz çalışmaya
devam edeceğiz büyük konuşmayı
öğreneceğiz hepinize sevgi ve saygılar
sunuyorum